tracking a killer
sky news can reveal the final hours of
one of the easter sunday bombers
muhammad nazar muhammad azer
pictured here in the town of batacloa
his target the zion church
the footage you're about to see is of a
seven and a half hour period leading up
to the attack
it's the most detailed record yet to
emerge
of one of the bombers preparing to
commit mass murder
at the top of the screen a bus carrying
34 year old muhammad azhar
stops in eastern sri lanka at just after
2 am on easter sunday
a rickshaw gives him a ride to
batakahloa an hour's drive away
he leaves the vehicle and walks to the
front gate of a mosque clutching two
bags
waiting outside in the dark pacing up
and down
at one point a police car drives up but
the bomber isn't spotted or doesn't
arouse suspicion
it pulls away
checking his mobile phone a hand in one
pocket
at 5 42 the gate of the jami usolan
mosque is opened
muhammad azhar walks in leaving his
deadly luggage inside the building
then heads towards the bathroom to
freshen up and take a phone call
he talks to another man at the mosque
and joins worshipers to pray seen here
on the far
right rolling up his tracksuit bottoms
slipping away early hand again in his
pocket
praying alone between two plastic chairs
then heading outside in a change of
t-shirt speaking on the phone
walking slowly on his back the same type
of rucksack as worn by the other bombers
seemingly scoping the area around his
target
it's now only minutes until the first
suicide bomb goes off in colombo
at that time he's back at the mosque and
back in his blue shirt
fetching shoes and socks going to the
bathroom one last time
40 minutes later again in his orange
shirt
a beige hat on his head bearing an
energy drinks logo
rucksack on his back
he walks to the exit digging his mobile
phone out of his pocket
head down as he writes a message
striding casually
stepping over a cordon on his way to
kill
a week on the faces of his infant
victims stare
out from banners pinned up in mourning
[Music]
at a church service in the nearby town
of katankuri they pray for the dead
muhammad azer was from this town he'd
been living away
but reappeared three days before easter
in the final stages of this deadly
assault
debra haynes sky news batacloa in sri
lanka